next story i want to get into is the
amber herd
with uh uh with johnny depp i'm assuming
you guys are following the story to an
extent there's only so much i can take
yeah i mean i i get that i don't even
know why it's public quite frankly i
think that's a private matter i don't
like the fact that it's that public i
mean we have other issues that should be
public that we follow that affects us
this doesn't affect us at all don't you
appreciate that they make the amber
heard johnny depp trial public but not
the epstein trial well listen
it it it says a lot by the way it says a
lot but let me kind of give you the
story
obviously it's been going back and forth
johnny got a lot of the story from his
end that's been out and you heard the
recording you heard her reaction his
finger being cut hey he keeps calling
her misheard misheard misheard he
finally files the divorce i don't want
to do anything i'm god you know i want
to you know and then she comes out and
the story with him her hooking up with
james franco and then her for one minute
dating elon musk and elon musk comes out
and says good things about johnny hey
listen i want to stay out of this but
you know her and i had a thing together
amber heard calls her trial the most
painful and difficult event in her life
as she kicks off testimony against
johnny depp amberhead began testifying
wednesday for a lawsuit brought by her
ex-husband johnny depp describing the
trial as the worst experience in her
life this is horrible for me to sit here
for weeks and have to relive everything
uh hear people that i knew some uh well
some not my ex-husband with whom i
shared a life with speak about our lives
in a way that they have this is the most
painful and difficult thing i've ever
done
uh i have ever gone through herd is the
second witness her legal team called to
the stand following testimony of don
hughes a clinical and forensic
psychologist
hughes who evaluated her and reviewed
therapeutic and
legal records relates to her diagnosis
and actress as post-traumatic stress
disorder caused by intimate partner
violence from dep hughes said that in
therapeutic sessions heard recounted
incidents where dep physically beat her
performed a cavity surge and penetrated
her body with a glass bottle heart is
expected to testify about those events
in the stand okay so
before you give your thoughts on you
know whatever other details you know
about it
so far
who do you believe in this story here
are you sitting there saying
you know i'm kind of believing what
johnny is saying i'm kind of believing
amber saying oh quite frankly i don't
know who the hell is telling the truth
where do you guys stand with this i
think they're both telling the truth
okay extremely toxic relationship
they're on the stand they're under oath
they're not allowed to lie and they get
caught in a lie that's big trouble well
at least for some people in court um
it is one of those situations where you
know the relationship obviously had so
much passion you guys have all been in
one of these uh that it just got
turned as as good as it got it it got as
bad as it got you know and uh
i kind of believe both of them um
what the result should be is you know if
either of them committed a crime and it
sounds like perhaps they both did then
maybe
there's charges that are pressed i i
don't know um
in terms of it being public well that's
uh
that's showbiz isn't it i mean it's
hurting their careers and helping their
careers at the same time do you think
this is hurting or helping their careers
individually it's helping johnny's
hurting amber's right now why do you
think it's helping his hurting her well
because he was the one that got
cancelled first before the trial came
out and we just assumed that he was you
know the guy who doing all the bad stuff
turns out she was doing the bad stuff
too and now there's a big online
campaign to have her removed from
aquaman too i don't think either of them
should be removed if you don't want to
see them in a movie don't go see the
movie
but their personal lives are personal
again these lines are blurred
it's people are so excited to get inside
the lives of these mega stars to feel
like i know them even better i know them
on a personal level i know all their bad
[ __ ] too and that's um
you know it's what it is i
i'm not a fan of that kind of interest
in people and the gossip and all these
stories but it is fascinating isn't it i
mean it shows the mental illness is
obviously an issue here
um
fame is a huge issue here power
and uh it's all on display in court
isn't it yeah you see like right there
what you're showing remove amber heard
from aquaman two how many people have
signed 3.5 million and a half million
first of all like why tell me why
yeah that's the job of the director the
movie producer casting agent if they
want to have her in or not but to this
is a form of a cancer culture right to
say hey get this girl out of it you know
if you don't want to watch the movie he
made a good point don't watch the movie
johnny depp disney saying they're not
going to be doing pirates of the
caribbean caribbean i posted
a picture of the movie on facebook and i
said johnny depp is the only jack
sparrow i know as a 43 year old period i
think that thing got like 100 000 likes
and 50 i don't know how many thousands
of shares people feel the same way and
because now someone asked him a question
they said hey if
disney paid you 300 million dollars and
they gave you xyz
would you still
go back would you consider going back
and being jack sparrow in you know
pirates of the caribbean he says no i
would not i mean that's a sad situation
because how the brand managed him
but all in all in a case like this
you said johnny depp wins and amber hurt
doesn't because johnny already had
tainted reputation based on what the me
too movement kind of thing yeah adam
where are you at with this well i
actually more just want to bring this
back to matt because you've worked in
hollywood you've been in movies you've
been around celebrities this you're this
is this is what you do you're an actor
and there used to be a famous line that
i remember that you would associate with
hollywood that you could say anything
you want about me as long as you do what
spell my name right
that was the whole thing with hollywood
just say whatever the hell you want just
get my name right okay well people are
certainly getting their names right
and that goes back to my is this helping
or hurting their career
does that still ring true in hollywood
does it is it's is it still like say
whatever you want as long as my names
are in the tabloids as long as my name
are in the headlines it's gonna be all
good just spell it right how do you
process that well i mean it's one of
these things where you've got to
separate the well you don't have to it's
your decision whether you want to
separate the art from the artist
um
i think johnny depp is a terrific actor
i also happen to think he's a violent
lover okay now those i can hold those
problem with a lot of our discourse
today is we don't it's black or white
right and usually it's all gray correct
yes and you know um michael jackson yes
r kelly exactly harvey weinstein i mean
they've they've done all very bad things
but they've also been responsible for
very good things right it's both so it's
up to you not as not uh society in my
opinion it's up to the individual and
what we're living through right now is a
time where society
whoever the decision makers
are
dictating how people should think about
certain things so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you